Krishna, and he said that, you know, the flow was less as compared to the previous states. Hey, hey, Sophia, how are you?
Hello!
Doing fine, and you?
I'm doing great. You know, on Fridays, I usually do great.
All of us.
Yeah, yeah, but this is the best part of our meeting, you know, that we meet on break note, provided the day of the week. So, yeah, how are you doing?
Yes.
All good, busy as always.
Yeah, I was checking this with Tammy as well, so...
Okay.
So let's make it quick and quickly jump into our agenda. All right, I'll start with Tammy. So Tammy, over to you regarding Krishna, how things are moving better.
Mhm.
Okay, I believe it's okay. No change really. She's doing the tax I've asked her. She is working on vendor statements, so that's new to her and we're working together on that. She has the idea what to do with the statements, but she knows that I need statements.
Reviewed every statement to receive in the vendor board needs to be reviewed, not ignored, but reviewed, and she's been doing that.
That's great. Thank you so much. Sophia, over to you for Sally.
Yes.
With Sahni, I think that we have...
Yeah, I think that if she's already finished with the training with payment application, she can do it alone. She's more confident on that, which is good. What I have seen is that when we don't have a lot of transactions, she just lose track of time and she do it more.
slowly and doesn't take care of the vendor, of the billing board. So that is something that I have to remind her, hey, you need to look to the vendor board. This should be finished one hour or two hours stop because we don't have that much at the beginning of the month. So that is something that she has to work in.
Okay.
time management and being proactive with the task.
Sure, I'll make sure that she does it. And the report that Tammy, you work on every Friday, I think on that piece, Sally has already updated the data. So I was checking with her. So she told me specifically by 1030 I was done with all the entries. So yeah, I think she's doing good there.
Yep.
Um...
Yes, we didn't have that much of entries today. We have like 35 or something like that.
Yeah, okay, great. And before I jump into the presentation deck, Sophia, Tammy, the CSER survey for the month of May will be triggered EOD today or latest by Monday. So I would...
Okay.
Message you on Teams the moment we trigger the service, so that you can please take out some time and put it for Tammy or Krishna and...
For sure.
Okay, I'll do my, yeah, I apologize, but yeah, I'll, I'll again.
No, no, it's alright. So, we have we haven't triggered yet, so once we trigger, I'll let you know, yeah.
Ohh, OKOK.
All right, I'll quickly share my screen and I have a quick ask. So I hope you are able to see my screen.
Okay.
Yes.
So this is the scorecard and the KPIs for Sally and Krishna. And I've been really looking forward to get numbers from you, where you see they are and how much they have scored in the last month. So in the email that I
I share follow this call. The presentation deck will be attached and I would appreciate if you could please update scoring for Sally and Krishna. You can either email me or you can message me over Teams. That'll be great. This is really essential because we are approaching the end of quarter two.
Sure.
So, so you know, we would need this data to analyze the overall performance of the analysts.
Okay.
Appreciate it.
Thank you. I will quickly go to performance analysis, starting with Krishna first. So she was able to take care of 56 vendor tickets during the period of May 28th till June 3rd. Out of those, we had 44 tickets linked closures and 50
additional POs, not without ticket number. She also handled 19 worked items, 8 follow-up emails, 10 were on all cases, and yeah, this is what she did. During this entire period, June 1st was the beat day where she did the maximum work.
where we had 27 vendor board items closed, including multiple expense record LCM closures and several invoice link closures. There was one need PO case that she also took care of, 2 on hold cases and three work cases.
Any questions, Tammy?
Okay, I will also ask Krishna, like at least half an hour a day, because we have a mandate to clean up our QuickBooks file, because it's way too big, and the file includes a PDF copy of invoices, of Ben invoices. So
Our ask was to move them out of QuickBooks into the accounting folder and then delete it from the QuickBooks. So that asked Krishna at least half an hour a day to do that task. So I forgot to mention that.
Kip.
She knows she's...
So, you want me to, you want me to do that, or you want to OK?
Yeah, no, just no, just reminder that no, this is this is her task, and she has been doing it, but I don't follow every day. Like, I don't expect it to check on her every day. She knows it needs to be done every day, but at least half an hour a day just to do that.
Alright, OK.
Got it.
Short.
Okay.
Any other questions, Tammy?
No, that's fine. No, I'm good for now, yes.
Thank you so much. Are we going to Sally?
But...
So for Sally, she closed 118 tickets during this period. All of which 75 were quick payment application, 34 were ConnectWise tickets, 12 queries, and two credit card payments.
So for Sally, her peak day was May 29th, where she worked on 109 payment applications, out of which 18 were bank transactions, 91 credit card payments, 13 service board updates, 3 queries, and two emails.
Sounds good.
Yep, I hope this data matches the data that you have at your end.
Yeah, it seems right. I don't track the tickets because some days we receive a lot. Some days we don't receive almost nothing.
Yeah, I get it. You know, so we what we have is we have a separate tracker where I keep record of a number of cases Sally and Krishna are working on. So towards the end of the week, I collate them and present it in this presentable form so that we can collectively go through it and analyze.
Mhm.
How was the best week?
Okay.
Yeah, this is from the data standpoint.
I would like that you remind to Sally that whenever she encounters with an issue in the payments, she has to mention to me and Natalie. We have an issue with a client this week is Southwestern. This is a complicated client.
Kip.
And she saw that the invoice has an issue because it was not matching QuickBooks ConnectWise and she didn't report it to anyone. Same thing, the client applied some credits that shouldn't be applied because it was applied to another invoice and same thing, she didn't tell anything to anyone.
So this kind of errors that she's catching, she should tell us.
All right.
For it.
I'll make sure that message is delivered to Sally, and she will follow.
Yes, please. Yes.
OK.
Kip.
I also put Sally, I did.
When the customer, I issued payments on to the portal, but I inadvertently overpaid.
And like I caught it, but I said, oh, someone should have told me that, that I made a mistake.
Mhm.
Oh, that's another thing too. Like, if she knows that this is some...
But it was number, but I paid too much. I need to know so that next month I'll change my payment, but I need to know if I made a mistake. And I didn't catch, if she didn't catch my mistake, I cut my own mistake.
Got it.
Kour.
Okay, I mean, I do look at it, but I want to know. Yeah.
Yes, it is another set of eyes. It's kind of a quality process, right?
Exactly, yes. Yeah. Like, don't accept it as this. Just say, oh, there's something wrong with it. Just let Sophia know or myself know that I think this is a mistake or can you please look into it.
I get it.
Yep, yep.
Mhm.
just a heads up so that I know that, okay, next month I'll short pay the difference to the customers so that I don't make a mistake again. So just like I'm all human, I make mistakes. So don't hurt, don't shoot me shy that I make mistakes. Like nothing wrong with that.
Every window, yeah, right, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, so I just want her to know that. Like she can come to me if I make a mistake, I made a mistake. Okay, yeah, yeah.
That's the generous of me, Tammy. Yep, I appreciate it.
Yes.
Yeah, that is the thing that I was trying to explain to Sally, that she is our set of eyes outside of what we are doing. So if we do something wrong, we need to know it because she is catching it.
Yes, yes, exactly, yes.
Yeah.
She shouldn't be afraid to say something, like, yeah.
Exactly. I feel that is something that being afraid to speak up. And she shouldn't. Yes. Yes, she should.
Yeah, speak up. She shouldn't. No, yeah, she shouldn't. She shouldn't. Yeah, I agree. She shouldn't.
Okay, I'll check with her if she's afraid or not or something else.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't know. I'm afraid of she doesn't want to talk.
Yeah, a little.
But.
Yeah.
Oh, she is pretty talkative, you know. She is.
Oh, so he's afraid then.
Popkin.
Alright, so what are your plans for weekend?
Um, nothing is really for me.
Uhh...
Yeah, me too. Just, I'm probably shopping at the mall.
Yeah, something like that.
Yeah, just out of the house, that's it.
But.
Yeah, out of the house, yes, finally.
Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
Great.
All right, well, thank you so much for your time, Sophia and Tammy, for coming on the call. And our next call is on 12th of June. So until then, you please take care of yourself. I'll see you next week and I wish you a happy and great weekend. Thank you.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, you as well. Okay, bye.
Thank you. You too. Bye bye.
Bye.